blackish i know that you're you're
continuing
to uh film the show how does that work i
mean i know what we have to do but my
job is
in in my job is obviously much simpler i
can speak to this camera in an abandoned
theater with socially distanced crew
you're
doing scenes with other actors
and it needs to mimic real life
how do you do that well the writers have
had
a really tough task the writers and
directors um
mostly this season we've had two-person
scenes so that we can keep a little bit
of a distance
um and sometimes you know as actors we
push back me being one of them i'm like
no i'm not hugging him
right you know um but they're really
amenable i mean
you know that's one of the things that's
had to shift for us uh we've been
working for two and a half months
everyone has stayed safe um the crew
wears a mask and shield at all times us
actors wear masks and shield except for
when we are
shooting so as soon as they say cut the
mask goes back on
um i think there's ways to do these
things safely
and to still be able to enjoy the
benefit of working which i feel so
grateful to be able to do and
safely i know that so many people are
not able to do that and i
i know the damage that that is taking on
our
economy and people's personal lives and
so i don't know it's been really
interesting but i think one of the
things that we've realized is you have
to shift the priorities of
how we have done our jobs so safety
is number one whereas it used to be like
how much can you cram into a day
right yeah you know the the other thing
is and this is a suggestion for your
writers they don't have to use it if
they don't want to
but they could write it in to the series
that you all became
welders yes wearing welders and
beekeepers so you're just
that's part of your character now you're
all you're shielded up all the time
for your character i would love that
i'll be honest um i am one of those
people but we do
have like banner our props master
um he wears a welder's shield and he has
a mohawk but we haven't been able to see
it all season
so he's put a mohawk on his
welder's cage that he wears
i don't know we've after two and a half
months we've actually found
some of the joy again um in in a new way
um i find it really wonderful to be able
to go to work it's made me
um so appreciative and grateful for what
um we are able to do
and i don't know i don't think the show
has suffered which is a testament to the
writers and producers
well i think that sometimes things can
even creativity can flourish in times
like this
you know i'm just reminded that when you
uh
really put strain and limit sometimes on
people they do beautiful things
so um i'm glad that you guys it's such a
funny show i'm glad you're making more
of them i'm glad you're continuing to to
do great work uh
so i'm appreciative for that and uh
i'm also appreciative that you're even
talking to me now that you're a
fashion icon because not many
not many fashion icons want to spend
i'm not getting a lot of phone calls you
know from i i don't know why you think
that
as soon as they said i was getting the
fashion icon award of 2020 i said
the first interview i will do and only
do
and if you can't set that up i'm not
doing anything else
that's right and you turn down oprah and
she's mad
but she's used to going she's used to
going second to me let's face it
oprah had to get used to that a long
time ago
she swallowed that pill and said you
know what i understand
i'll take a step back